alright here's a Pulitzer prize-winning
journalist and founder of define
American please welcome Jose Antonio
Vargas Jose how are you sir how you
doing great to see you ok first of all I
have to thank you here I know you are
literally risking deportation because
you are not completely legal is that
correct yes so I am one of the 2.5
million undocumented residents of
California 800,000 of whom lived in LA
County so thank you for inviting me well
we hope you know I talked to Roger stone
I guess we'll try to figure this out
yeah not a bad guy to have on your side
so what about the the fact that Jeff
Sessions is going after sanctuary cities
this is a sanctuary state pretty much
and the first of all tell us what that
means sanctuary well actually I think we
have so politicized this issue that I
think it's really important that we
define our terms yes so it is safer
right for all of us documented
undocumented euro citizens
if undocumented people who live here can
feel comfortable reporting talking to
the cops right saying hey something's
happening something right now in LA
the LAPD reported that 25% decrease in
reporting of rapes in the Latino
community because there's fear that once
you report right somebody ice might come
get you right and for me to like the
bigger issue here and you know Jeff
Sessions the former governor of Alabama
who believes in state senator oh the
former senator of Alabama who believes
in states rights when he was governor I
mean when he was Senator of Alabama the
fact this overreached telling the
federal government telling for the
federal government to tell the states
how they can protect the residues is
hypocritical at worse but to me I
actually think it's really important you
mentioned this right now there's going
to be a bill in front of Governor Jerry
Brown's deaths asking him to sign the
California values Act that would declare
California a sanctuary state I think
given that this state is home to a
fourth of the
he's undocumented population and this in
the state nearly half of all children
have at least one immigrant parent right
hopefully Jerry Brown signs that into
law so but how many people can come here
I mean I hope you think of America like
a lifeboat and a lot of the world is a
raging ocean so everybody wants to get
in the lifeboat and certainly everybody
has a right to be happy in the world but
if too many people get in a lifeboat
then the lifeboat goes down having
traveled to Montana South Dakota North
Dakota it's not like we don't have me
immigrants come to this country and
build businesses there's actually room
when immigrants come here documented or
undocumented they start businesses like
I for example I'm a business owner I
employ 15 US citizens I'm protecting
people who are here as US citizens and I
provide jobs as an undocumented person
so I think for me it's a matter of the
fact that there is no path you know
someone right now on Twitter saying why
can't this guy just get legal probably
right the fact that there's no path for
people like me to actually fix this get
in line wherever the line is and try to
get legal and do right by the law the
fact that there's no way to do that also
there's the hypocrisy angle you
mentioned this but this was in the paper
in the LA Times wages rise on California
farms listen listen to this there's a
labor shortage yep they're giving
laborers benefits normally reserved for
white collar professionals 401k plans
health insurance subsidized housing
profit sharing bonuses still not
tempting white people to do yard work
white people do not want to do yard work
that's what it comes out to the
president Titan farms are up the peach
grower he advertised 2000 jobs from 2010
to 2012 he hired four hundred eighty
three hundred nine didn't show up two
hundred and twenty-one quit in the first
two days only one only thirty-one lasted
the whole season he said we've never had
one come back after lunch
can you imagine this is the issue really
to me is that they don't want these
people here but they won't do the job
and they will not admit it and we put a
sign outside of the US Mexico border
saying keep out then ten yards in what
do we say Help Wanted right right that's
right right yeah can you imagine it out
ready what this city cannot function
without undocumented workers the thing
Texas one point eight million
undocumented state of Texas can you
imagine undocumented people not working
the state of Texas half of the
construction industry depends upon them
and this is why I think the opportunity
of being here I have to tell you I
cannot I cannot overstate the level of
fear the level of confusion that our
families my grandmother is probably
watching right now go in like why is
your television you should be hiding so
I can't overstate that enough actually
my my being here is my form of
resistance I will not be scared I will
not be scared
to be public and out in a country that
has been my hope the question now is all
of you here I'll be watching how are you
doing to provide sanctuary to us in your
churches at your schools at work eleven
million people a lot of a million adopt
many people live within the 43 million
immigrants in Syracuse you're doing well
actually right now you know this is
woman Jeanette des Guerra in Denver she
has taken century at a Unitarian Church
because the Catholic Church that she
belongs to did not want to help her out
she's gone to all these churches and
she's right of providing sanctuary to
the priests